guys guys guys
did you hear?
THERE’S FOUR NEW ELEMENTS.
Dang it, now I have to change my shower curtain.
Hey guys Julia here for DNews
Main
This week the The International Union of Pure
and Applied Chemistry (IUPAC) announced that
four new elements will be joining the other
114 on the periodic table of elements.
The addition of elements 113, 115, 117 and
118 means the seventh row or period is now
complete!
They still don’t have proper names yet,
they’re just called by their numbers.
So where did these as yet unnamed elements
come from?
Scientists from Lawrence Livermore laboratory
in California and the Riken institute in Japan
smashed atoms together in particle accelerators
and these new elements were created when the
two nuclei fused.
But the new elements existed only for a fraction
of a second.
Then they decayed into isotopes of other elements.
Element 113, the one created in Japan, exists
for less than a thousandth of a second before
it decays into other isotopes, so it’s unlikely
you’ll run into this element anytime soon.
So alright, sweet new elements.
While cool, it probably won’t mean much
for your daily life, yet.
Unless you have to memorize the entire table
in chemistry class, sorry 10th graders.
But for science, it could be huge.
Scientists have been searching for the elusive
“island of stability," which according to
a theory by Nobel laureate Glenn Seaborg is
a stable element with just the right number
of protons and neutrons.
And these new elements might be getting scientists
closer to the island of stability.
You see, most heavy elements, ones with more
than 113 protons like these new ones, only
exist for a short amount of time.
That’s because the force of the positive
charges of their protons is too strong and
the nucleus is pushed and pulled apart in
a fraction of a second.
But just like atoms become stable when their
outer electron shells are full, some researchers,
like Seaborg, believe that if a nuclei has
a certain number of proteins arranged in just
the right way, the element would be stable,
it could last.
If we can create this theoretical stable element
it could be used to build things we haven’t
even imagined yet!
Even the effort of doing so, teaches scientists
"a tremendous amount of just basic nuclear
physics."
According to Seaborg, the magic number to
hit is 114 protons and 184 neutrons.
And after 30 years of trying, Seaborg’s
mentee Ken Moody finally hit the sweet spot
by slamming together plutonium and calcium
which briefly created a new element.
Unfortunately, while the element, now called
flerovium, or Fl has 114 protons it doesn’t
have the needed 184 neutrons, and so it fell
apart too quickly.
Element 117, has been heralded as a possible
“shore to the island of stability”.
Five years ago, A U.S.–Russian team first
created it at the Joint Institute for Nuclear
Research in Dubna, Russia.
Described in a journal Physical Review Letters,
this new element has a half-life of about
50-thousandths of a second.
Which means in that short of a time, half
the element will decay into other isotopes
like lawrencium-266, which had 103 protons
and 163 neutrons, a combination never seen
before.
This lawrencium-266 even lasted a long time
for an isotope, with a half life of 11 hours.
Because of this, one of the lead authors said
“Perhaps we are at the shore of the island
of stability.”
So, maybe, science is one step closer to creating
a new element which we could use in ways we
haven’t even dreamed of.
And though we’re not there yet…we’re
getting closer.
It’s clear more research is needed.
There’s no theoretical limit to how big
elements can get!
One day scientists might just start filling
out the elusive 8th row!
So don’t change your shower curtain just
yet.
so what happens now with these new elements?
What happens when new elements are added to
the periodic table?
There is trial and error in science constantly
but what did it really take to perfect the
gold standard tool that hangs in every chemistry
classroom?
to find out, trace has the answer over on
Test Tube Plus